the upcoming midterm elections with just
over six weeks to go both parties are
throwing down the political Gauntlet
Friday House Republicans outline their
vision for the country if they retake
the majority that would set the stage
for a minority leader Kevin McCarthy to
become the next Speaker of the House CBS
News Congressional correspondent Nicole
Killian spoke with McCarthy just outside
Pittsburgh where he made the
announcement
traveling from Washington DC to
Washington County Pennsylvania we've
created a commitment to America minority
leader Kevin McCarthy unveiled House
Republicans midterm agenda we want an
economy that is strong in addition to
the economy and fighting inflation the
four-part plan focuses on border
security and public safety education and
government accountability if they trust
us with the majority this is what we'll
do leader McCarthy banking the message
will help him win the majority and the
speakers gavel why do you want to be
speaker well I want to for the country I
want to win the majority so we can have
a new plan and implement it they'll make
that decision after the election and
whichever way it goes from that
standpoint it'll happen the latest CBS
News Battleground tracker estimates the
GOP could gain 13 seats for a total of
226. five makes the majority but we want
to compete everywhere former speaker
Newt Gingrich lit more than 50 seats in
1994 as the architect of the con
contract with America which served as a
model for McCarthy's plan how many seats
do you think House Republicans can pick
up
oh they're somewhere between 15 and 70.
70.
this is a paper contract with America
commitment to don't give me a commitment
do it
I don't want to hear your words what I
want to see is your action Democratic
leaders including President Biden
pounced on the Republican platform
that's a thin series of policy goals
with little or no detail
Democrats hope abortion rights will help
Galvanize voters this fall though it was
only a brief reference in the new GOP
agenda would you pursue some type of
national or Nationwide abortion ban well
you're seeing a national debate on this
we're a part that respects and defends
life Republicans also remain mom on the
former president now embroiled in a
series of high-profile investigations
you're not worried the former president
some of these issues he's dealing with
is going to blunt your message going
into November I think the number one
question America has is can they afford
what's going forward the minority leader
is expected to take this agenda on the
road going from District to District in
the run-up to the midterms now just over
six weeks away for CBS Saturday morning
Nicole Killian outside of Pittsburgh